[Music]
[Applause]
he's Ross Tucker our good buddy the Ross
Tucker football podcast he has got
double duty on Westwood One radio this
weekend in the booth with Kevin Harland
Saturday night Dolphins at the Chiefs
then working the sidelines Sunday night
Rams and the Lions okay let me start
with the weather in Kansas City and what
role does that play in this
game well first of all Dan you'll
appreciate this because I knew I'd be
getting two games this weekend I knew
one would be sideline and one would be
in the booth so when my boss hoe denov
said okay Saturday night you're in
Kansas City I thought oh my goodness
last I checked there calling for
ne5 I thought he was putting me on the
sideline thank goodness I'll be in the
booth
it has a Major Impact now listen I
played in one of the 10 coldest games in
Buffalo Bills franchise history which
ironically Dan was in Cincinnati
Cincinnati's like on the Kentucky border
I had no idea got that CT in Cincinnati
I mean it was freezing it was so bad
that after the game you had to start
your shower almost cold like lukewarm at
best otherwise your skin would sting it
would I mean it stung anyway but the
warmer the water the more it would sting
your skin from the Frostbite the
important thing to note about the
weather is the ball expands it gets
harder it's hard is a rock so when I was
a center Dan I hated the colder it was
because I don't have huge hands right so
the bigger the ball would get the harder
it is the harder it would be for me to
grip so what does that mean that means
that's an issue for the quarterbacks
it's definitely an issue for the
receivers because it's like they're
catching a rock that is as hard as you
can imagine full of air plus I think it
leads to a couple fumbles it's almost
like you're you're carrying this uh this
balloon that's totally filled to the Max
and it's it's waiting and ready to pop
out it's going to have an impact on the
game for sure and then Buffalo 10-point
favor s with wind and snow up there how
does that impact that
game probably helps the Steelers right I
mean usually when you're an underdog
especially a big Underdog the worse the
weather conditions are the better it is
because it levels the playing field a
little bit I don't know that I feel that
way Saturday night with the guys flying
up from Miami where it's 70 some degrees
and all of a sudden having to experience
that in KC I don't care where you're
from originally it's hard to get your
body acclimated to that whereas for the
Steelers I think it helps them right I
mean I don't Envision them throwing the
ball over the place anyway if this
becomes a game where both teams have to
run the ball a lot could be an old
school Steelers game Naji Harris is
finally in my opinion Dan started to run
like a Steelers running back you know
like Barry Foster and Bam Morris and uh
Jerome Bettis I mean that's kind of this
game the way it needs to be for the
Steelers and that's that's how Naji
Harris has been playing that's how the
Steelers offensive line has been
blocking I think the worst the weather
is in Buffalo the better chance the
Steelers have although it's still very
much an uphill climb for them without TJ
wat I think I saw a stat where they're
one and 10 without him the team that may
have a coaching change if they lose this
weekend who are those teams if any yeah
um well it sounds like there's enough
speculation out there that it sounds
like Dallas is one of them and that
wouldn't surprise me I mean if they lose
at home to the Packers I think that
would be real bad for Mike McCarthy
because there was already some
speculation that they might do something
last off season I think McDermot
probably solidified his position based
on these last five games winning the
division getting a home playoff game
number two seed but if he lost to the
Steelers there might be some questions
asked and then the last one because I
you know I do a lot of stuff in
Philadelphia they're asking it a lot in
Philadelphia right now is Nick serani
now that would surprised me but the last
couple games I mean this stretch it's
been bad really bad if they go out there
on Monday night and lay an egg and lose
by 20 points well then Howie Roseman the
GM Jeffrey Lorie the owner they're gonna
have to figure out what the heck
happened here where the team went from
10 and one to totally falling apart and
then they have to decide whether or not
ser iani and whoever he would hire maybe
for both coordinator positions certainly
you would think defensive coordinator
whether or not serani is the right
person to get this thing going back on
track and and get the right coordinator
hires he's Ross Tucker Westwood W CBS
sports analyst and former offensive
lineman spent one season with the New
England Patriots obviously very
emotional for you for Bill bich to uh
step down there I'm guessing right all
your great memories with Bill bellich I
I think you might have asked me this
before I think he said something to me
three or four times the whole time when
I first got signed that day he walked up
the steps in like the theater room the
team room and I stood up to shake his
hand and all he said was you don't need
to get up that was it you don't need to
get up I don't even think he said
hi um one time that first week of
practice I fell on the ground and he had
this unbelievable ability Dan to like
say something to you
without even looking at you or letting
people know he was he walked by me and
all I heard was somebody in the corner
of my ear say stay off the effing ground
will you that's it that was it it was
really it was a bonding experience um a
couple weeks later we played the Jags in
the playoffs and my my college teammate
was starting at Center and he said again
walked by never made eye contact we got
half the freaking Princeton team in this
game okay and then uh and then they
traded me and I actually talk to him for
the first time they traded me I went in
his office and everything I sat down he
told me why they were trading me to
Cleveland so yeah it was emotional um
all the pictures all the memories the
moments we have I will say this though
Dan in all
sincerity I got a lot of questions about
this so now it comes out that it was
written into Mayo's
contract that he was belich successor
right I guess I'm assuming that bellich
knew about that and was okay with that
but it's still a little awkward right I
mean if you're the
successor don't you want to take over
and start making the Six Million or
eight million whatever it says in the
contract like Mayo's probably making a
million bucks maybe two and it probably
says in the contract well when you take
over you're making six seven or eight
whatever it is don't you want that to
happen as soon as possible yeah but it
was written into the contract take the
coach three more years no it was written
into the contract TR 2024 was when this
was supposed to take place that he would
take over for belich next season and
therefore Bel they probably thought when
they signed this deal that belich would
surpass Don schulin the oldtime victory
list uh but still if you're bellich
you're you're signing up for that
literally signing up for that that you
and the Patriots at some point no you're
going to part ways here he was trying to
keep his job I think for maybe one more
year
but you know it's written in Mayo's
contract so he got the succession plan
so it was just kind of strange that
bellich would then just move on from the
Patriots after 2024 yeah and I'd also
say this Dan I think it's a missed
Opportunity by the Patriots right what's
so interesting is that when you play in
New England and I was their 05 and then'
06 all they talk about is the process
the process the process right it's not
about the results it's about the process
I'm a little surprised Dan that the
Patriots didn't use this opportunity to
at least interview some other guys I
mean they've been bad the last few years
wh Why not pick the brains of some of
these coaching candidates and say what
the heck you think's going on with us
like why why are we so bad what would
you do Ben Johnson or Mike Vel like
whoever what would you do if we made you
the head coach to just give the job to
Mayo and by the way everybody Raves
about him I don't know him that well
well but literally everybody says he's
awesome great guy maybe he'll be an
awesome coach but I'm just surprised
that such a process oriented franchise
didn't interview anybody because also if
you interview people Dan then you can
say yeah we interviewed these six guys
but Mayo was clearly the best instead if
you just give it to Mayo man if he gets
off to a bad start or if things don't go
well you're really opening yourself up
to heavy criticism regarding the process
or lack thereof well also you're going
to have a rookie coach who's never been
a head coach and you're probably going
to have a rookie quarterback in there
maybe again now I know it worked for
Houston but they're an outlier when it
comes to a rookie coach and a rookie
quarterback and Dan you're hiring the
head coach before you hire the GM yeah
which creates a very unique Dynamic
right like usually the GM is kind of the
coach's boss because the GM is looking
out not only for the short-term interest
of the of the franchise but the long
term whoever they hire as GM they're not
Mayo's boss I mean that Mayo is going to
be part of hiring them I mean and they
had nothing to do with mayo getting
hired it's a really strange Dynamic if
you ask me the most attractive coaching
vacancy is
what I think it's I think it's hard not
to say the Chargers and and I'm aware of
their cap issues for next year but
you can manipulate the cap a lot you can
you can restructure contract look they
could just take all the pain this year
and then be good to go 2025 and Beyond
or they can restructure guys manipulate
guys what's the thing that all these
open jobs have in common right the
Titans and the Falcons and the Raiders
and the Patriots and whoever they don't
have good quarterbacks they don't they
don't have top 20 quarterbacks you it's
it's really hard to win or have
sustained success
without a top 20 guy all these guys that
got fired none of them have top 20 guys
you could argue maybe Pete Carroll Gino
Smith still top 20 maybe but they were
they made the playoffs last year winning
record this year the Chargers have a top
10 guy nobody disputes that that should
be where you'd want to go because I
don't care about the draft choices in
Washington or New England you could
draft a guy and it might be CJ Stroud or
it might be Bryce young and you don't
know which nobody does it's a 5050
proposition it feels like I'm going to
the Chargers I think they got lower
expectations out there the media is not
that bad and you have Justin Herbert and
some other really good pieces around him
he's Ross Tucker have fun this weekend
Saturday night Kansas City and the
Dolphins he'll be in the booth with
Kevin Harland and then Sunday night Rams
at the Lions so uh you know you don't
have to you're walking the sidelines in
a dome there how much pressure is on
Jared G in this
game well yes first of all I'm thrilled
that I'm on the sideline indoors I mean
Dan that the first home playoff game in
30 years that's going to be bananas I
that's gonna be a top five football
environment of my lifetime I think
there's pressure on him because of the
fact that they're playing the Rams as
much as anything else and it's
interesting when you hear his quotes
this week it he's still not over it so I
don't know if that's a positive or A
negative I don't know if that's a chip
on his shoulder but he's a Cali kid who
was playing in La he loved it he loved
everything about California being out
there I think it still bothers him that
he got traded to Detroit and he really
wants to show the Rams and McVey that
they messed up I don't know maybe that's
great and he goes out and plays really
well or maybe he tries too hard and
turns it over a couple times but there's
definitely pressure on him he'll be the
guy next year but if he really performs
poorly then the people in Detroit will
start that conversation up again is he
the guy that can get us to the next
level in the postseason have fun this
weekend thank you Ross thanks man I will
that's Ross Tucker Westwood One CBS
sports analyst